la parole est à madame valérie la côte
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
ministre il y a une semaine
vous annonciez la mise en oeuvre d'un
plan national de sécurité publique
chiffré à 250 millions d'euros afin de
répondre à la colère de nos policiers
après avoir tenté de minimiser leurs
mouvements vous répondez au malaise
qu'ils expriment par quelques effets d
annonce
comme si ce malaise n'était pas assez
profond face à des individus de plus en
plus déterminés et encourager dans leurs
agissements délictueux par l'absence de
réponse pénale immédiate
nos forces de police réclament des
conditions de travail plus digne et plus
sûr dans ma circonscription le
commissariat de fontainebleau en est un
illustre exemple un les plus vétustes de
france où les fonctionnaires travaillent
dans le froid et l'humidité entassés
dans des algeco ce commissariat
nécessite une attention urgente pour
mettre fin aux conditions de travail
dangereuses et indécente de nos poli et
malgré la coopération et le soutien des
services de l'état au niveau local et la
volonté de l'activité locale même
financière aucune étude de faisabilité
n'est lancé aucune certitude que le
projet de rénovation de ce commissariat
soit inscrit dans le programme
pluriannuel 2017 2020 comme vous le
savez monsieur le ministre
les collectivités locales sont
mobilisées sur ces questions de sécurité
pour exemple ma commune nemours où j'ai
mis en place de la vidéoprotection
recruter des policiers municipaux et
asvp créer un parking pour le
commissariat armée mais policiers depuis
plusieurs années et les actions sont
nombreuses
monsieur le ministre il est grand temps
de répondre aux attentes de nos
policiers par de meilleures conditions
de travail
il est grand temps d'accompagner les
collectivités la halle
surtout quand elles sont prêtes à
s'investir financièrement ne me répondez
pas par l'argument des suppressions
d'effectifs 44 ans et demi vous auriez
pu si nécessaire qu elle aussi l'état
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
bernard cazeneuve madame la députée
merci pour votre question j'ai senti à
la fin la tentation de faire et votre
question et ma réponse je vais essayer
de filet le plus précisément possible la
réponse bon d'abord vous me dites que
faut-il faire et que faisons nous je
n'évoquerai pas les sujets que vous ne
voulez pas que j'évoque parce que j'ai
trop d'estimé pour vous pour vous
contrarier
même si ces sujets correspondent à une
réalité mais depuis le début du
quinquennat
nous avons créé exactement 6638 emploi
dans la police et dans la gendarmerie
nous avons recréé des unités de forces
mobiles nous avons augmenté de 15%
les crédits d'investissement dont
bénéficient les forces de l'ordre ce qui
nous a permis par exemple des cas
irlandais renier près de 7000 véhicules
pour la police et la gendarmerie et d'en
acquérir pour l'an prochain c'est ce qui
est un prévu dans le budget près de 6900
donc la volonté du gouvernement depuis
maintenant cinq ans c'est de faire en
sorte que par les créations d'emplois
par l'augmentation des crédits
d'investissement par l'augmentation des
élèves aussi dans les écoles de police
il y avait 450 élèves dans les écoles de
police en 2012 il y en a quatre mille
six cent cette année nous puissions
progressivement faire face à une
situation qui résulte d'années et
d'années d'abandon et de déshérence de
les services de police et de gendarmerie
nous avons annoncé un plan la semaine
dernière qui est un plant de 150
millions d'euros ce plan va permettre
d'acquérir des matériels de protection
il va permette d'acquérir des armes
il va permettre d'engager des
investissements immobiliers dès le mois
de novembre et l'augmentation du budget
de 837 millions d'euros budget du
ministère de l'intérieur pour l'année
prochaine permet d'engager des
investissements y compris dans les
commissariats qui jusqu'à présent
n'avait pas été envisagée donc le
commissariat de fontainebleau qui depuis
1943 a été construit et en déshérence
fera l'objet d'investissements de la
part de ce gouvernement
alors que pendant dix ans vous n'avez
pas la parole est à monsieur pour